i miss seeing you every sunday
i really do thank you that's so sweet
i like taking the breaks from it all i'm
sure you guys don't like the social
media or anything it's nice
right it's a lot to take in speaking of
social media i swallow i have to ask you
kalani's dad is teaching you how to play
golf yep we
we're doing seriously we like go every
day we practice like every single day so
even though it costs a lot of money i
told him
if we do it we need to put all our
effort in it
so if we do it better this is our job to
make some good money but tell her your
big names what
what big news for your game yesterday oh
so yesterday my i think
two days ago yes so since that we play
with
my dad in lord this is the first time i
beat him
he won for the first time wow congrats
and my dad's really good at golfing so i
was impressed yeah
oh wow you should be a really good coach
yeah i make uh
two birdies but i don't know okay you
made up two birds
i played golf too so i know yes
go ahead well that's a major improvement
last time we checked he was ready to get
physical with you i swallowed
so talk to us a little bit about how
your relationship with kalani's dad has
improved
um so now it's like
because that time we're not really
hanging out together spending our time
together but
now he he work in california but
since the epidemic so he lives with us
and uh raining too so the way today it's
it's the rainy day it doesn't work when
it rains so he's been spending a lot of
time here
so they've been like yeah so how do you
feel about all of this kalani because
you were in the middle
i mean this is your husband and your dad
and your dad is ready to put his hands
on your husband
how do you feel about it um i think it's
great
it's obviously a lot nicer for me to
have them
getting along but sometimes i'm just
like because then my dad will side with
him or like
pick things that he does that's
irritating but i'll take the piece 100
the piece is worth it i love that i love
that well in october
you put on instagram that you two are
trying
how is that going what can you tell us
um i don't know i think the pandemic has
been really hard for all couples
and we already had a bunch of other
issues going into it so
i think we just have been trying our
best and that's just where
we are i feel like it changes on a daily
basis
like a lot of marriages i don't know i
think we're in an okay spot i wouldn't
say that we're
in a great or perfect spot but i think
we're i think we're good we're working
we're both putting in the effort so it's
not it's not
horrible like it was but it's not
amazing we're getting there that's what
i'm trying to say
there i would say we we are heading to
the right way
yeah we're on the right track
that's good so that must mean that you
don't have
you don't have that temptation to leave
like you did before kalani because you
were on the verge of walking out
do you still feel that at times or
or not let me be honest
um i just think marriage is very hard
and i think that when you have
a lot of other issues like cultural
issues and
language issues and all of these things
it just makes it very complicated so
i think for right now we are trying our
best and
hopefully that works out but i mean you
never
really know yeah well something i'm
curious about
is your love for asuelu it's very
obvious that you love
this man you're a lucky man other than
your kids
what is it that keeps you there what is
it that we don't see when the cameras
are rolling
that you two share amongst each other um
i i think gosser has a very sweet
soul and i think a lot of people have
seen that from the show but
obviously last season was a little uh
different
but i know he's a very good person and
i'm attracted to nice
good people so i think that anytime i
feel like i'm at my breaking point or
ready to be done that's kind of what
lures me back in is that he is
at heart a very nice person and he's a
funny person too
he really and that too these tick tocks
are soiled
me cracking up they're hilarious
how much fun do you have creating those
tick tops
um i like all the things that going on
this
way just waste my time to like think
about the past and things but
for me it just have fun with my life and
fun
what i have just the thing that keep me
my energy going up and yeah
like making some people like i know some
people they have some bad days and stuff
like that but
i'm here to make them happy and to make
them smile that's all i want i just
don't want them
to hate each one my mother so i just
want them to have
love for each other and it's working i
i've sent a couple of your videos to my
friends
and we all just enjoy them my favorite
one is when you do the mariah carey song
and you take the blanket off and you're
like
it's so my favorite too that was so so
good
yeah i was just like guys i'm
not you don't make me do this every
single time
[Music]
i don't want to lie for christmas
so how do you feel about the tick tocks
kalani because i know one of them he had
your dress on did you help him come up
with these ideas
that one made me mad not because he did
anything but because he tried on like
all of my clothes and left them on the
floor so then i was like if you're gonna
borrow
my stuff at least hang it back up and
put it away but other than that i
thought that was really funny too
i think it's good i think uh the
pandemic's been really hard for a lot of
people so anything that can make you
happy and
put a smile on your face and other
people's face is great
hey careful
where are you going
season five of happily ever after i
swallowed there were a lot of
ups and downs a lot of rough patches how
do you feel about how you were portrayed
um i think uh that thing that's not who
i
am i watch it and i hate it and i
don't want to be that person so
i but it's good you know when it's good
i learn
it's a good lesson i learn from that and
growing up and yeah just be good change
and be a better
person yeah i think oh sorry
i think too it's just made him be better
because a lot of people attacked him so
it made him look at himself and think
yeah
i put probably shouldn't talk like that
or do things like that so
i think overall it probably helped our
relationship more than anything
do you still block kalani when you're
mad at him
even though you st you stay in the same
house you still block her
um no not anymore i think that was the
last time that you left me
also progress
okay kalani this is a question that so
many people want to know
how is your relationship now between
asuelu sister tammy
and his mom how what is the dynamic map
like now
um
[Music]
same as it's ever been i don't i don't
have a relationship with them so he
he does the talking or whatever he wants
to do with them and i just kind of
sit on the wayside i don't i don't have
anything to do with them
and it's not a work in progress like you
in and asuelu's relationship it just is
what it is
um it is what it is let's just say that
well kalani for the last what three
years now you've been
immersed in this world where people have
all these opinions about your marriage
about
your life how have you learned to deal
with all of that noise
um you know the first season i was on
was so
difficult for me i was not ready for
everything that would happen of people
being in my business but
i think once you pass your first season
and you do other things you just get
used to it it's just
it's a part of my life now so i just
don't listen to negative things
block block that's what i do it's just
the block
button is heaven on earth and i use it
all the time so
that's how i creep it keep everything
clear and
makes me happy yeah what about you i
swear i know a lot of people had
opinions about
one that kiss with your mother a lot of
people have their opinion
um how do you deal with other noises
yeah every same way
i just block but i just pray to god to
place their soul and their mind
i'm not just like hating them but i just
bless them
they have a good life like me because
now i'm living in my best life so
i want them to have the same thing too
you're a better person
right right i love that that's a nice
way to look at it
a positive way to look at it well the 90
day universe continues to expand and you
two are expanding with
it there's a new competition series love
games
and you're part of it tell us about what
fans can expect
um a lot of fun a lot of
familiar faces we had a really good
experience with love games it was
it was really fun okay so this is on
discovery plus and it's a legit
competition
so there's a trophy and everything at
the end i know you can't tell us how far
you made it
but can you at least tell us who was
your toughest competition
what couple um
i feel like that's just something people
will have to wait and see
right yeah we but we did there was one
couple in particular
that they knew each other really well so
i was like yeah we're probably gonna
lose
i think uh loud games was a really
nice challenge for most of the couples
because for me i didn't know
other things that my wife liked it but
after the
love games man i studied
everything about first of all
if we go to maybe if we go to another
season or another um challenge we gonna
win
right baby now being on love games made
me realize
that we don't know anything about each
other really
other than like oh what's your favorite
color anything in depth we were just
like
uh we we need to work on that we get we
need to get to know each other better